think it really is a way to set your you
know the the last quarter of your life
in a way that you really enjoy it i
drove myself into the ground
with bad diet bad sleep bad habits of
every kind what the [ __ ] was i thinking
[Music]
so i guess let's start with what you're
working on because this project is
really exciting and i loved hearing that
it's something that's been in the works
for a while so tell us what's cooking
you know
new television formats are are very
difficult to launch anytime but
particularly during a pandemic but i've
been working on this for a while because
i think fundamentally it's a really
interesting idea the concept is if you
think about um what's happened during
the pandemic we've got tens of thousands
of cases litigation primarily business
litigation
stuck in the court system because during
the pandemic there was no courts and so
they were taking care of very serious
crimes but not the ones that affect
business
and 65 of jobs in america are created by
small business often these are family
businesses that started were successful
and they grew up but anytime there's a
conflict in a business like that it can
be devastating to the value
inherent and also damage relationships
with customers employees
shareholders you name it and so it's
really important when you have
litigation to try and settle it
and what has happened through the court
system is that arbitration has become a
way for two litigants to settle and
resolve their issues all we're doing in
money court is is actually recording
that and people have actually agreed to
allow me to actually be an arbitrator in
their case and settle it for them
in addition i brought with me two
fantastic co-hosts ada pozzo who's a
former federal judge sat on the bench
for many years and also katie fang a
trial attorney
and uh it's a it's a remarkable format
because
we deal with the real thing real cases
real litigation
people in turmoil and it makes for very
compelling television
was there something about that like did
it feel like a lot of pressure for you
to make that decision or you feel like
no you have a good solid understanding
of what feels fair and just you know i i
do this every day i've got over
34 companies in my portfolio and every
day there's drama there's always
litigation or
some catastrophic news or some euphoric
news i'm used to it every day i mean
every day something's happening and very
often i'll find myself in the middle of
a
a really difficult dispute and and the
key
that people should understand is nobody
makes money in litigation except the
lawyers most of the time so if you if
you can actually
solve it get in the middle and be
trusted by both sides
um to find a resolution that's a far
better outcome for the business and the
shareholders and what i found so
interesting in the in the journey of you
know when we were casting the cases and
and the lawyers et cetera
one person said you know i'm going to
agree to do this and let mr wonderful
decide for me
i don't like him that much but i trust
him
and i'm very i'm very happy with that
outcome actually
yeah i mean i was there some part of you
that there's like a little bit of
validation in this and in oftentimes in
legal disputes i feel like
things
the law will sort of side in ways that
don't necessarily always make sense to
us as the entrepreneur as the business
owner like they'll they'll sort of find
like legal loopholes to get something
done so was there any part in this
process where you got to sort of make
something the way it should be instead
of the way like legally it would
typically get resolved that was what was
great about the format because yes i had
a federal judge and i had a trial
attorney and they really understood
the law and the contract law and what
the law says but the final decision was
always mine and i said i'm going to
decide for the business because the
business sustains all the employees all
the shareholders all the customers you
have to always solve for the business
not one individual over another and
that's sort of
how i judge these cases and and i'm very
proud that afterwards in the post
interviews that i didn't get to see
these people abided by my decisions
because they felt they were right and
and you know that's i think that comes
from experience of having to have done
this every day for decades and so i i
think the format itself is going to do
quite well because
people see themselves in these cases
even though they're gut-wrenching in
some situations a mother suing a
daughter siblings fighting you know
family torn apart because of money
they they've seen it before in their own
families and that's why i think it's
very compelling
you're kind of
realizing it can happen to anybody and
hopefully everybody learns from these
outcomes
yeah for sure
i'm curious like you talk about you just
said you have 34 companies in your
portfolio
can you take me back to
how how did you make the transition from
i own a business or i'm an entrepreneur
i'm i'm doing this thing too i'm
building a portfolio i have you know i'm
a holding company i'm this bigger thing
was that a conscious decision or was it
something that happened organically no
it happened organically and i've talked
to many others that are in my situation
that kind of do this and started looking
at opportunities and became an investor
in multiple operators and used my
experience to help them and
and then the next thing i knew some of
those companies were successful and we
sold them and and then i just
started you know repurposing this
capital
and i don't need more money i like to
keep what i've got obviously and i make
mistakes sometimes when i invest but
luckily i'm fortunate that
the majority of the times they're
winners and um they generate more cash
to do more investments with so i'm sort
of like a uh
investor uh
you know advocate for ceos yeah
uh you you said something it reminded me
have you ever read the book shoe dog yes
by phil knight
you know when he talks about it's sort
of the worst day of his um he's you know
being dramatic but he talks about it's
like the worst day of his life when he
finally sells the business or when he
finally retires because it's sort of
like what do i do now you know what what
do i do now that i've had all this
success and i've done all these things
and
and you know it's it's the
not the hustle but sort of that activity
that so many of us has have partaken in
as entrepreneurs for so long like how do
you let it go so i love and i'm
fascinated by people like you who kind
of take it and then help others
come up in that way yeah i've been you
know money does not buy you happiness
but it makes being miserable a lot
easier that's what i like to say
that's real that's super real
uh so as you as you look to the future
is that still a big part the investment
piece is still a big part of what you
want to do are you kind of leaning in
this new direction
with um you know judge jury and all the
things like you're doing on the show
there's there's an emergence of of
social media and media can now affect
market capitalization stock prices and
we've seen it happen with the meme
stocks and what's happened with you know
tesla and what's happened with reddit
and robinhood and all these things and
what i found is the fact that i have
millions of followers can really affect
the outcome of a business
if you know and so people approach me
all the time saying look will you can we
pay you some stock options so that
you'll promote our business i say no i'm
not going to do that
but if i like your business i'll buy a
third of it and i'll become a founding
partner and i'll help you blow it up
people can smell bs a mile away on
social media i don't care what venture
capitalists pay and what valuation they
pay i don't care about any of that i i
sit down with the entrepreneur and say
look i don't care what your last round
was at here's what i'm willing to pay
you
to buy a third or whatever it's going to
be
and
after that i'll participate in every
financing we do but i'm going to i'm
going to change your world nobody can do
what i can do for you and and and you
know
there are there are no venture capital
guys that have millions of followers
they they don't i do and i understand
the difference
why do you think you've been so
successful have you ever like summed it
up in your mind of you know here are
these guiding principles that have led
me to this place i think it's something
my mother taught me when i was 14 and i
never thought of it at that time and it
affected me years later she said to me
once if you always tell the truth you'll
never have to remember what you said i
think
maybe not everybody likes you
but they respect you and i think
maybe that's you know
i i don't i find that you know people on
social media
even the ones that don't like me follow
me and you know harass me saying i hate
the way you said that or you did this
but they're still following me i mean
why
um when you
are investing in companies are you
looking for specific types of companies
or you've sort of invested across the
board like it's a pretty pretty broad
portfolio i have a really broad
portfolio i mean it's almost in every
sector in almost every state and i've
got technology companies that do
wireless power transmissions i've got
insecticides i've got commercial
kitchens that make cupcakes um you know
i've i've got
d5 and
cryptocurrency deals and all kinds of
stuff and and what i find is the
outcomes are unknown i mean they're just
serendipitous in some ways so the
portfolio itself
um
is constantly generating cash because
everybody knows i'm a royalty guy or i'm
a debt guy or whatever it is but i also
do equity deals
but
and then once you know every like even
yesterday i got a phone call from one of
my companies and they just got offered a
a huge uh premium to be
you know acquired and they're asking me
you know do i do i want to sell my
position i said well let my guys look at
the deal i mean
you know i generally want to return my
capital and put it back to work again so
and that's going to be a really
successful outcome and i would have
never guessed it two years ago you just
don't know that's my point
yeah so so if you're if you're working
with someone and let's say we have a ton
of small business owners who listen to
this podcast let's say you're walking
they're lucky enough they get a day with
you or maybe it's an hour because your
schedule isn't safe they get some time
with you you're walking in to to look at
a company what are those elements that
you look at if you're trying to advise
someone and sort of help them to grow
that bottom line or expand reach what
are the like hard and fast like you
always look at these things in a new
business
well
well here's a fact that um
that is kind of interesting and i've
been doing this for such a long time but
over the last 13 years
75 percent of my returns have come from
their companies run by women
when we went back and looked at the data
from these outcomes remember when you're
investing privately it's return of
capital that's most important not on
capital you've got to get your principal
back and women-led companies women are
very good at mitigating risk and so when
we actually looked at
quarterly sales objectives over a
five-year period in the first study and
then over seven in the second
we found that the the companies run by
men hit their targets in terms of
revenue about 65 percent of the time but
the average growth rate was the target
was 30 percent annually which is very
good but they only hit at sixty five
percent of the time
and then we looked at the women red
lead companies they hit their targets 95
percent of the time almost 195
but their growth on average over that
seven year study was only 15 percent
they're half that of the men and the
reason it works and why we've adopted it
as our new philosophy is when you set
targets that your team reaches
95 of the time the culture in the
company
changes it becomes very sticky people
don't leave so the person running
accounting or sales or logistics or
compliance
in a business can be very disruptive
when those people leave for whatever
reason but when a team is humming and
it's working and hitting its targets you
have no disruption and cash flows are
much higher so i'm a little biased now
when you ask me what do i look for i
look for a woman running a company
that's
that's what i so that's you know and i
don't want to be sexist i don't want to
start gender warfare but i'd give money
to a goat if i get a return
but but but i i prefer to invest in
women
that's awesome and i feel like it's
something that's so important for the
women who are listening to this to hear
because i think a lot of times
they don't put themselves out there they
don't try they don't look for capital
they don't because it's just sort of
this innate thing of like oh i'm gonna
play small and i'm gonna play it safe
and i like hearing
that in some instances being a bit more
cautious like being cautious but hitting
your goals as opposed to setting these
like astronomical we're going to aim at
the moon and get there some of the time
really is paying off for you guys yeah
it is it is and we've have a lot of
empirical data it's been so long
and so you know we just know it
intuitively we kind of
you know we meet various ceos we look
for those attributes risk mitigation
because you know things are going to
happen you know as
i like to say in business [ __ ] happens
and you got to be you got to be able to
pivot nobody saw the pandemic coming and
that really changed america we all
jumped to the digital pivot direct to
consumer all of that stuff that happened
over the last year and a half has been
really important in determining who is
our winner and who's a loser in the
portfolio
how do you see that continuing to shift
because i think obviously
i feel like in the beginning we pivoted
once now it feels like we're pivoting
once a quarter and it's going to
continue to change the economy has been
affected i don't think we've seen
anywhere near the fallout of that that
we're going to like is there something
that you're sort of looking at in the
next you know 6 12 months that it's like
you're feeling good you're feeling like
winter's coming like how are you feeling
about where we're at
we made the assumption in december
that 15
of the staff would not return they were
primarily in the jobs of accounting
compliance and logistics because they
they sit in cubicles at headquarters and
they've gotten used to working remotely
and successfully so and you know from
suburbs raising children or taking care
of elderly parents whatever it was
and so we planned in in for this year
the first six months to downsize our
corporate headquarters by about 15
percent but that's not the outcome
it's over 35 percent do not want to
return more than double and they're just
saying we don't want to live that way
anymore i don't want to commute for an
hour and a quarter into chicago or new
york or miami or detroit whatever
they're willing to come in once a
quarter maybe once a month or something
but not often and i think that's a one
permanent change in america and the
other one that has really been profound
and we've saved a lot of money as a you
know results of reducing commercial real
estate we've even
there's been so much direct consumer
change in our product mix that there's
many stores we're never opening again we
don't need them we've got the customers
back direct the other thing is business
travel and entertainment we that budget
has been slightly cut in half i don't
think we're going to be doing that much
anymore because we can do it on zoom and
we're successful with it and people say
oh don't worry it's going to come back i
don't think so i think it's going to
take a very long time there are
permanent changes in behavior
and i think you have to deal with them
as a result of what i call digital
america 2.0
you talked about you know at the
beginning of our conversation you talked
about this idea that at any given moment
you can pick up your phone and there's
could be a celebration to be had or a
crisis to be had you have so many
different companies and that's just
what's going to happen [ __ ] happens in
business right so
how do you manage the stress of that do
you feel like you're used to it at this
point you've been in it for so long or
are there things that you do to make
sure
that you're managing your you know
adrenal fatigue or you're managing your
cortisol like what are you doing to make
sure that you can maintain we get data
weekly um tear sheets on revenue and
free cash flow those are the only two
numbers we need to look at because we've
been in these businesses for years it
gives us the it's like it's the ekg of
the business those are the two numbers
you need to look at because they're
private we don't care about stock price
revenue and free cash flow because if
something's happening on the top line
it's declining we need to know that if
something's happening on the income
statement we need to know that because
reduced cash flow but generally we're
able to manage with those two numbers
and we we generally speak to our
companies once a quarter
although they call us uh for social
media support all the time you know we
we enjoy a huge presence on network
television on cable and social media on
all of the things we do it's
storytelling that's what we're doing and
we're adding
reducing customer acquisition costs on
these companies because that's the
number one reason companies got a
business in america today they're never
able to get their customer acquisition
costs below the lifetime value of the
customer they go bankrupt advertising
that's the problem and so we try and
avoid that with our companies and we're
pretty successful at it
and how are you then like does it feel
stressful for you to manage all these
things or you just like this in my life
i've been in it for so long yeah that
the more the latter this is my life i've
been in so long every day there's just
catastrophe somewhere i just dealt with
it an hour ago and another euphoric call
like the one i told you about on the
takeout offer that's the same day it's
sometimes in the same hour it's so i
like for me it's sort of
let's reduce that hypertension you know
we're going to have the [ __ ] happens
metric and we're going to have the
euphoria and neither of them are
you can't let either of them dissuade
you that much
i can't i can't let it stress me out
sometimes i make money sometimes i'll
lose money you just never know
yeah
um how important is health it looks like
you're wearing a whoop strap or some
sort of is that what that is on your
wrist yeah i'm wearing i'm wearing a
whoop and i'm also wearing you know an
aura i i uh yeah i listen to really
tracking yeah no it's really interesting
because i i'm in a group called the
longevity league which was founded by uh
the former ceo of magna very big car
parts company i own some stock in and he
he would hold these online seminars and
invite guest speakers in
uh that had various interesting research
going on in longevity and cognitive
health and i'm you know i'm into that
and one day i listened to a presentation
by
richard isaacson from
cornell
and he had just recently been published
in various medical journals including a
long article in in the wall street
journal
and his basic thesis
very simple was that he can arrest
dementia
can't cure it but he can arrest it with
exercise
diet
and sleep
and i was just fascinated you know i
just listened to him and i just went wow
i got to get into that guy's protocol i
mean i want to try that
and i sat down with him
in my home in miami or his offices there
by zoom and went through a huge battery
of cognitive testing and then a whole
series of different tests that i agreed
to and wanted to become part of the
protocol
and that guy really changed my outlook
and all of this stuff all of it he's
he's monitoring all my diet all of the
fasting i do i never used to think about
diet i'd say everything in moderation
when you eat well it changes your life
it does and you know i love asking this
question because i think
when i was earlier in my career you know
15 16 years ago as a younger
entrepreneur
i would run myself into the ground like
not eat all day or have a ton of
espresso or not get enough sleep you
know that was sort of the hustle
that
i was younger than too but sort of
thought that that was the way to you
know achieve all the things and i am
wildly more productive effective focused
energized now that i understand how to
take care of my health and everybody
that i know who's a high achiever
whether that's as an author a speaker an
entrepreneur whatever it is everybody i
know is focused on it and cares about it
and so i always tend to ask because i
think it's important especially
for younger entrepreneurs listening to
this who are working parents who are
trying to figure it all out they'll pour
everything out to the business so
they'll pour everything out to everyone
else and not have anything left in the
tank for them
and
really if you own the company
the success of the company is
very equated to how well you are mindset
body energy spiritually like are you
okay because if you're okay you can take
care of the business and if you're not
you're [ __ ] yeah i i you know i
totally agree with you and i only wish
that i had met him while i was an
operator in business because i did
exactly what you did i drove myself into
the ground
with bad diet bad sleep bad habits of
every kind what the [ __ ] was i thinking
it is really nice to have one less thing
to think about and i love food like i
love a beautiful meal with like
multi-courses and you're celebrating
with friends and it's an experiential
thing but day in and day out i'm just
going through my work day
i i'm breaking my fast with a green
smoothie it's disgusting i nobody wants
to eat this this is not but it's so
freaking good for me and i feel such a
difference in my life so i just i wanted
to touch on that because i do think i
think everybody listening should try it
it's only it takes it takes three weeks
to to adjust and then all of a sudden
you're doing your body such a favor by
bringing that insulin that glucose down
and it's just it's because you got to
think about it in the old days people
did not snack all day long on shitty
food they never did and you're working
out people are working out of their
house now the kitchen's right there
yeah it's a it is a game changer and i
do think i when i started it last year i
think i started it maybe in covet and
i'd heard about it forever but i thought
that's not for me that's whatever
i can't believe how much energy i have
yeah i know it's amazing i cannot
believe how much it changes it it's
fantastic and i think it really is a way
to set your you know the the last
quarter of your life in a way that you
really enjoy it so you said something
that that sparked a thought for me you
talked about being in a group it was you
know about longevity but i'm curious how
much do you think that
sort of our proximity to
like-minded people or even people who
are further along than us affects our
success in life like do you have a group
of
friends or fellow entrepreneurs or like
a mastermind or people in your life that
elevate your way of thinking and how
important has that been well speaking of
the longevity league we also had a guest
speaker come in and talk about you know
happiness in life which i thought was a
great topic and what he concluded after
much study you know academic study is
that relationships long-term
relationships smaller groups because you
can't have friendships with 200 people
but if you have strong relationships
with 20 to 25 people in your life you
tend to be happier long-term so you know
i obviously you know have a lot of of
noise coming into my life through social
media and everything else and and i
spend my day doing television all the
rest of that stuff
i'm on tv four hours a day sometimes
five hours doing exactly what we're
doing here because i'm supporting all my
companies and my projects but you know
my relationships stay constant they're
all around the world and i i go out of
my way to stay in touch with those
people uh because you know that that is
the baseline for
what gives you a reason to exist kind of
thing you know not just family but also
friendships that matter to me over time
and as they say you can't make new old
friends and so you should really cherish
your relationships with those if you've
known for a long period of time and the
only way to do that is to make time for
them i recommend that for everybody
because you know
we're in a social media world now and
just
tweeting all day long or putting out
posts on tick tock well i really believe
in those platforms for supporting my
businesses that's not exactly uh you
know staying in touch with your
long-term friends
if you like that video wait did you see
my next one don't forget to click right
over here and subscribe